hey friends so September 8th marked a
very auspicious anniversary that was the
date I uploaded my very first tech blog
to this very YouTube channel and got the
ball rolling on what's turned out to be
the biggest project of my life I've been
trying for a month now to figure out how
exactly to commemorate this Milestone
and I have to confess I'm
still well I'm still pretty lost on how
and even if to do so lately I have been
having some feelings about my channel
and its future as well as the future of
the flow arts in general and it feels
kind of odd to celebrate something that
I feel so conflicted about currently it
doesn't help that at one point I was
planning on hosting an in-person event
to commemorate the anniversary that
wound up falling through for a variety
of reasons it's hard to feel like a
success when you feel like you've just
had a major failure and as it turns out
having some self-doubt is kind of par
for the course with these big
anniversaries I went back and took a
look and discovered I was likewise
struggling back in 2018 when I was
observing the 10-year anniversary of
this channel I tend to get a little
depressed on my birthday too so it could
just be that that's baked into big
Milestones like this for me but despite
all that I figured that this was still
an occasion that I'd want to look back
and say that I observed and celebrated
in some form so here it goes it's
definitely weird thinking about having
done this now for 15 years and having
been doing it full-time for more than 10
that was definitely not the plan when I
got started when I first picked up PO I
thought it was just going to be a fun
hobby to help keep me fit as I was
following what was then my primary
passion of Human Rights activism I
didn't even share my videos when I first
started posting them to my YouTube
channel I kind of just let them sit
there like a Personal Diary of what I
was working on with my pois spinning so
if I have some gratitude to share the
first person who likely deserves it is
alien John John was the person who
shared my videos when even I wasn't
doing that on a thread on the home of
poi forums asking about po 1.5s John
shared my first four Tech blogs and lo
and behold I suddenly had viewers and an
audience unexpected but cool my goal at
the time was simple record a new video
every week of the poy tricks that I was
working on it was something that kept me
practicing and forced me to engage in
accountability around trying things out
every week where so many people I knew
that started spinning po at the same
time I did fell off with it at some
point my video diary goal kept me going
with it and that consistency wound up
being crucial for building an audience
looking back on these early videos it's
more than a little bit embarrassing how
bad the audio and video quality is I was
shooting most of these with a point and
shoot digital camera that I gotten for
Christmas or when I'd forgotten to
charge the battery for that just the
camera on my laptop the results were not
inspiring but it was good enough to show
off the stuff that I was talking about
good enough that other people could tell
what it was I was trying to do and good
enough for people to keep tuning in and
as it turned out good enough to convince
fire festivals to let me teach for them
though I never thought of them as being
explicitly to tutorials a great many
other people did and they helped me get
onto the teaching lineups of so many
festivals that I found myself having to
choose between my day job and traveling
the world spinning poi spoilers I chose
the letter and this wasn't smooth
sailing at all I remember my first day
of unemployment becoming painfully aware
of the fact that when I had my
traditional job I could dick around on
my laptop for a few hours in the morning
and I'd still be getting paid but that
wasn't the case anymore being
self-employed meant that money only came
in the door when I was directly engaged
in activities that would help bring it
in this realization led to an enormous
amount of anxiety that has never really
completely gone away and it left me with
a huge unanswered question if indeed I
was going to spend POI fulltime how
exactly was I going to earn a living
doing it there were local entertainment
companies that would hire me out for
gigs but the work wasn't exactly
consistent I taught classes at a local
dance studio but the attendance could
really be hit or miss and I tried flying
around to different cities and teaching
workshops but I struggled to break even
on these excursions the first real
breakthrough happened for me when I got
a hookup for a company willing to sell
me stage balls wholesale and thus I got
into the business of selling contact po
through my website this was a big
GameChanger for me in that it gave me a
stable if somewhat labor intensive
source of income at a time when contact
poy were in high demand this was the
first time I didn't have to subsidize my
income through taking consulting or
programming gigs in order to make ends
meat and it was also unsustainable in
the long run for me the labor to create
contact po was expensive and at first
I'd failed to factor it into the cost to
produce each set that I sold
entrepreneur side note labor costs are
absolutely a thing and you'll find that
out real quickly when somebody other
than yourself has to make a thing which
will happen if you want your business to
grow as I tried to expand and bring in
help I found I wasn't well suited to
running HR as it turns out businesses
require a lot of really specific roles
to flourish and I just wasn't good at
many of them I realized that I could
rise to the challenge of making my
business grow but that it would take
time away from creating content and that
was my true love so in the end I let
that part of my business go and I'm
really glad that I did teaching PO is my
core competency not making po but by
then a brand new tool was available for
online creators like myself that allowed
us to pull something like a stable
salary and even better than that connect
with our most passionate and Ardent fans
I am talking of course about patreon I
actually avoided joining patreon for a
couple years because as a programmer I
reasoned that I could create a clone on
my website that was good enough and I
didn't want to give up any part of my
income to patreon's admin fees and in
the end I have to admit that the system
that I built was kind of a nightmare to
navigate and I bit the bullet I signed
up for patreon and in the process
discovered that sometimes paying for a
cleaner user interface and a trusted
brand to interface between you and your
customers is actually a really great
move patreon saved my channel make no
mistake so if there's a second dose of
gratitude to dispense out there it's to
Jack KY for creating the platform and
the hundreds of people who've signed up
to it over the years to support me and
the content that I wanted to create and
so I was able to create content and I
had Financial backing for doing so but
my channel was still really small by the
standards of YouTube I really began to
question whether I'd ever be able to
make a sustainable income doing what I
was doing how exactly was I going to
make this anything more than a hobby
that brought a trickle of money in with
it that's when an old friend connected
me with a mutual friend from college
somebody who'd seen other internet
entrepreneurs build their businesses and
agreed to chat with me about how to
build mine I gave him a lot of push back
too I was skeptical of nearly everything
that he suggested from email list
building to offering parts of a course
I'd spent months working on for free to
get people interested in taking the rest
and you know what he was right about
everything so our third bit of gratitude
here definitely has to go to will cisk
and his very patient coaching sessions
with me as I was gradually realizing I
wasn't just an artist or an educator but
also an entrepreneur and it was also
about this time that I discovered
keyword targeting was a thing that lots
of people would look up similar things
on Google and YouTube and if you played
your cards right and optimized your tags
titles and video descriptions right that
you could rank higher in search
and this absolutely changed the game for
me instead of slow incremental growth my
channel saw exponential growth I was
ranking in common searches alongside
videos that I considered to be
revolutionary and had been deeply
influential to me and this was about the
time that I started seeing my name pop
up next to those of my Idols as a
resource to go to in order to learn po
i' started keeping track of different po
channels and their growth on YouTube and
quickly realized I was on Pace to
outgrow everyone else within a few years
it felt really cool and then something
happened that utterly transformed my
mission and my Channel's prospects the
co 19 pandemic everyone was stuck inside
for lockdown and I instantly knew that I
could help people were going to need
things to do to keep themselves busy at
home things to keep them fit to give
them new challenges to engage in and to
give them something to focus on other
than the state of the world and I had
just the thing so I took material that I
had been working work on for a brand new
po beginner series to offer on my paid
course site and I repurposed the
material for daily tutorials i' put out
there to the World on my channel I would
record a week's worth of videos all in a
single day and spend the next 5 days
editing and posting each video so people
could wake up to a brand new challenge
every day I kept this up for nearly 3
months it was exhausting but It sped up
my growth like you would not believe and
even better than that brought in so many
new people to learn from and support my
work that I reached a longtime goal of
getting my income back to where it was
before I left my last traditional job
all from spinning poy it felt like an
incredible accomplishment of course 3
years have passed since all that went
down time definitely got a little mucked
up thanks to the pandemic that feels
like it was both yesterday as well as
eons ago and that kind of brings us to
the present day and what I think is
going to be my final piece of gratitude
in this video and that's for all of you
out there watching learning and
supporting my work I don't get to the
point where I'm making a comfortable
living without tens of thousands of you
out there contributing your attention
energy and support to my work I cannot
emphasize this enough this was not the
plan when I started my channel this was
not even the plan several years into my
channel and it would never have become
the plan were it not for all of you out
there tuning in this glorious and
frequently ramshackle experiment
wouldn't have worked at all if you all
hadn't been there and so after 15 years
more than a third of my entire life all
I have to say is thank you from the
bottom of my heart thank you for
everything y'all are the reason that I
get up in the morning and brainstorm
topics for new videos y'all are the
reason that I learned how to properly
use a camera and light a studio y'all
are the reason that I wrestle with Final
Cut Pro and Adobe Premiere believe me I
wouldn't bother otherwise and y'all are
the reason that I put this stuff out
into the world constantly and in return
I get to see y'all grow and Blossoms
flow artists seeing people take the
stuff that I've taught them and Shining
with it absolutely makes my day you have
no idea I get to see the scene grow and
evolve and mutate over time I get to
meet really amazing people who change my
perspective and teach me new things
about the world I get to feel the love
of thousands of people out there
watching and supporting the work that I
do so thank you one in all it's been a
truly amazing ride this past decade and
a half I've had good times I've had real
bad times but I've gotten to do
something that most people only ever
dream of and for that I'm really
grateful thank
[Music]
you and with that I should also put out
some thank yous to the people that are
supporting my work currently starting
with the friends of the Channel big
thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling pyate
light toys spinballs and Ultra poy for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links down in the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non- business friend of the channel
Becca Bean thank you so much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission and of course this video would
not exist without the wonderful support
of those of you who've signed to support
me on patreon special shout out to my
flow patrons who are listed on screen if
you like what I do don't be afraid to
check out my patreon and sign up you can
do so for as little as a dollar a month
and every little bit helps if you'd like
to check out other videos that I've done
on my own history and the history of
others I'll include a link to a playlist
of those videos down in the description
as well as up on screen if you're
watching on YouTube thanks so much for
listening to me wax nostalgic about all
this be sure to get out and flow today
and I'll see you with a new video real
soon take care now peace